perry
de nombreux internautes depuis la nuit
dernière sans confrontés à un virus
informatique qui a déjà terrassé des
millions d'ordinateurs dans le monde
entier un virus d'un genre nouveau qui
infecte n'importe quel ordinateur sans
même qu'ils soient actionnés suffit
simplement qu'il soit branché les
explications nécessaires de marie-pierre
samitier et christian galley voici le
nom de ce nouveau virus ça sert un
dérivé du virus blaster qui avait
infecté des millions d'ordinateurs en
août 2003 il se répand automatiquement
il suffit que votre ordinateur soit
branché et qu'on clique sur le
navigateur de windows
les systèmes en danger son windows 2000
windows server 2003 et windows xp avant
le virus se propage effectivement par
courrier électronique via une caisse
joie qu'il fallait ouvrir pour pouvoir
de l'ordinateur maintenant il a gagné
trois étapes encore plus rapidement
critiqué uniquement sur le navigateur
internet explorer
le virus dans votre machine symantec
l'un des leaders mondiaux des antivirus
donne déjà des détails sur son site pour
éliminer le nouveau virus acer se
répandit ton encore plus vite sur les
ordinateurs branchés en permanence sur
internet notamment lorsqu'ils disposent
d'une connexion adsl